however a common mistake in the
interpretation of Statistics is that a
correlation is immediately assumed to be
a causal relationship here's an example
the American statistician Daryl Huff
found a negative correlation between the
number of head lice and the body
temperature of the inhabitants of an
island a negative correlation means that
people with many head lice generally
have a lower body temperature and people
with few head lines generally have a
higher body temperature the Islanders
concluded that head lice were good for
health because the reduced fever so
their assumption was that headlights
have an effect on the temperature of the
body in reality the correct conclusion
is the other way around in an experiment
it was possible to prove that high fever
drives away life so the high body
temperature is the cause not the effect
what are the conditions for talking
about causality